[Music]
you
okay hi everyone thank you for joining
us my name is Carl white Ulysse and I'm
a second year MBA student here at the
GSB I'm joined by Heather one of my
friends and classmates in their second
year as well so today we'll be talking
about our experiences at the GSB both in
and outside of the classroom and we'll
be answering as many of your questions
as we can
we won't be talking about the admissions
process financial aid or the application
but we have some people from the
admissions office who are going to be
available via chat or you can email them
as well just if you want to submit a
question you can just click the Q&A
button at the bottom of your screen and
then we'll be able to see the questions
in live just to start maybe we can start
with introductions so maybe heather if
you can start by telling us a little bit
of yourself where you're from what you
did before the GSB and what you're
planning to do after graduation
sure hi everybody my name is Heather I'm
and I am as Carl said a second-year MBA
student
I am a born and raised Midwesterner and
I spent the last four years in Chicago
working in management consulting before
coming to the GSB I came to the GSB
because I was really focused on making a
pivot into social innovation and this
seems like the best school in the
country to do that and I here at the GSB
I've been involved in a lot of things I
was on our GSB impact fund which is our
impact investing group I helped with our
admit weekend and and this year I'm an
Arbuckle fellow which we can talk a
little bit more about it's a program
focused on coaching and mentorship I
spend the summer at Rafi's they're a
sustainable shoe company and I'll be
going back there full-time after
graduation
congratulations thank you as for myself
my name is Carl as I said I'm originally
from Montreal in Canada and prior to the
GSB I was working as an anesthesiology
resident physician so working mostly in
the operating room and as part of the
trauma and cardiac arrest teams at night
Hospital I came to the GSB because I was
interested in health care systems reform
in health care administration and want
it to be bilingual in some way be able
to talk to both clinicians and
administrators and here at the GSB
I'm also an Arbuckle fellow like Heather
I am also involved with the student
Association as chief operating officer
and I'm a member of several clubs
including the black business Student
Association she's B pride and the Health
Care Club my summer was spent in two
parts actually my for the first part I
worked at Bain & Company the management
consulting firm and then for the second
half I went back to my old job at the
operating room to see some patients and
after school directly after I'll be
finishing my residency but do have a
return offer to join Bain and company
full-time afterwards so maybe we can
start with some questions so Heather why
an MBA what made you decide to come here
do an MBA and why now yeah that's a
great question so from me um I went back
and forth on whether I wanted to get an
MBA for a long time and it's something
that is pretty typical for consultants
so I knew that it was a an option for me
although not a necessary feature to
continue my career um I honestly if I
have a piece of advice its apply before
you know that you want to go I went back
and forth and from the time you applied
to the time you actually leave for
school takes a year so in hindsight I
probably should have applied a year
previous to go and I was actually ready
to go and but ultimately I just decided
that I kind of what had an epiphany in
terms of what I was doing wasn't what I
wanted to do for the rest of my life
anymore and it seemed like this was a
really good way for me to do that
self-reflection and spend two years
doing some exploration and figuring out
where I wanted to go in my career and
what I was looking to get out of it and
I think I've gotten that here yeah I
think I have a pretty similar story for
that I tried to balance essentially
having enough experience that I felt
like I
knew what my role was as a doctor and I
knew I had experiences to share with my
classmates but also had time to come
back after finish my residency and still
catch up with my clinical work when I
came back I think the other thing is
leaving the salary of a resident is very
different than leaving a salary as an
attending for two years and so I was
more comfortable doing my MBA earlier in
my career before my earnings start
jumping up significantly so for our next
question what made you decide to apply
and choose Stanford over other schools
mm-hmm yeah so I'm I applied to a bunch
of different schools I have my husband
actually lives in Chicago and so we were
making this a lot of these decisions and
tandem and so a big piece of it for us
was where could I go to school where he
could easily find a new job so we were
really looking in major labor markets so
no small schools for me in kind of the
middle of nowhere so I was really only
looking at schools in big cities and
then I was really focused on the
curriculum and what I could get out of
it and I knew for me that looks like
social innovation so I was looking at
schools that had great social innovation
programs and then great design thinking
programs those were kind of my two
criteria and so ultimately that ended up
being a handful of schools and when I
got into Stanford I was like but these
were the things that I was looking for
so it was kind of hard to deny that this
was the place to be awesome
yeah for me I think one of the big
things that I was looking for was a
school that also has a very reputable
healthcare system associated with it
because shockingly I'm interested in
health care also I was super attracted
to the focus that Stanford has on
personal development and leadership
development and all the classes that are
available here to work on your
leadership brand and learn more about
how other people perceive your
leadership behaviors was super
interesting to me and I think the last
thing is being international I wanted to
go to school that had some brand
recognition
in my home market since I know that I'm
planning to go back there after
graduation okay next question Carl how
was your experience in the beginning of
the mba course considering that you did
not have a traditional business
background hall did the school help you
during this tradition this transition
period I think there's a few different
things first having a non-traditional
background and the first few quarters a
lot of the classes are tiered so there's
a base level an accelerated level and an
advanced level and so for me who hadn't
hadn't taken accounting before and knew
very little about finance it was helpful
to take the base classes in some cases
accelerated it's also appropriate where
as my classmates who came from finance
or consulting backgrounds were probably
skewed more towards the accelerated and
advanced classes also we got sent
materials over the summer that we could
look over if we needed to review certain
things mainly in math and statistics
which I looked into a little bit and
there's also a lot of tutoring resources
that are available for us to access all
throughout our two years on campus I
think one of the other interesting
things to note there that is a GSB
specific thing is we have an academic
adjustment period for the first six
weeks of your first year you're not
allowed to join clubs you're you know
recruiters aren't allowed to come to
campus and those six weeks are purely
for you to kind of focus on getting your
feet underneath you academics wise
mm-hmm yeah that was definitely useful
for me as someone who's never City
business before next question Heather
can you speak a little bit more about
the social impact opportunities at
Stanford and unique programs this school
has in the space hmm sure so we have a
one of the biggest resources here on
campus is the Center for social
innovation and they are sort of a
conduit or a plethora of resources for
you in career preparation and as well as
plotting your academic journey so when
you come to school they sort of talk to
you about your your two-year roadmap and
beyond that what does it look like once
you leave the GSB and they bucket you
into one of I think four categories so
you might be a career switch or you
might be an industry vet or you might
just be an explorer it's just kind of
interested in the field
um so based on that that kind of help
give you guidance on what to do I think
one of the other great resources that we
have available is you can actually get a
certificate here a certificate in Social
Innovation and Public Management and we
are a generalized and BA program we
don't do specific tracks that's one of
our only certificate programs and so I
think that's been a really great way to
sort of add a credential to my MBA
showing that this is an area of focus
um and then I joined a lot of sort of
social impact type opportunities in
terms of clubs so we have a club for a
sustainable business we have a club for
social innovation
I joined our impact fund and sourced
impact or social impact startups that we
would invest in and and then I am the
CEO of the challenge for charity which
is the largest and being a nonprofit in
the country and so they were things that
were important to me and I found ways to
work them into my not only my coursework
but my extracurriculars and just other
opportunities yeah my internship GSB
focuses a lot on shaping leaders what
kind of leaders and what are the
leadership values that form the ethos of
the GSB do you want to start sure I'll
start um I think a big thing that I've
learned during my time here is that
there's not one kind of leader that can
be effective there are so many people
who are extremely different than me here
and they're just as effective as me if
not more and a lot of different
situations and I think a big strengths
of the GSB is that they help you narrow
in on what your brand is and what
situation and what situation is this
brand effective and in what situation
could you tweak it in a way that still
feels at an authentic to you and I think
in terms of what they look for passion
is certainly something that resonated a
lot with me when I was visiting the
school when I was talking to students I
think it's not
incidents that the question in the
essays what matters most to you and why
they really want to get at what you're
passionate about what drives you what
gets you out of bed in the morning I
agree with all of that and I think if if
you were to ask people just out in the
general public like what is the brand of
GSB leadership and they would probably
talk to you about how we're in touch
with our feelings and our emotions and I
would say that's definitely been a big
focus intentionally of my first year and
a half um has really been doing this
self-reflection and identifying what I
want to get out of being a leader or
being in business and what it is that
drives me what it is that I'm passionate
about and how I want to show up to other
people and I think one of the most
valuable pieces of the GSB is that
there's just this assumption here that
everyone has the best intent possible
and there's this culture of feedback and
it's really a gift to other people to
let them know how you perceive them and
how they're showing up to you because
that's not always information that you
get in the real world and so what you
may intend to do based on how you're
speaking or what you're doing may not be
how other people perceive it and so
that's been a really valuable part of
this experience to me is understanding
how my intent differs from the impact
that I have on others and and so I think
that that is a self aware leader I guess
is where I think the GSB tries to push
us yeah definitely agree with that
next question what was your most
memorable experience at the GSB I want
to start with that one
I'm sure wow there's so many um well my
first challenge for charity weekend
which was last year was a really great
culminating experience of a lot of hard
work throughout the year and then also
an opportunity to host other business
schools here which helped us or helped
me see GSB through their eyes which is
kind of fun um I'm trying to think that
I also loved our Vegas foam so our foam
is just a weekly social event that we
have on Tuesday nights and and it's just
like a kind of a happy hour type
experience and
so you're we all dress up in 70s clothes
and we take a cheap Southwest flight to
Vegas for the night and then we come
back and that's not normally something I
think I would participate in at this
stage in my life but it is really fun to
do with 200 of your closest friends and
so that was a very memorable experience
and and then otherwise I think just the
friendships that I've made and the trips
we've taken together and that's been a
big part yeah yeah I think for me also a
lot of these travel opportunities have
been really memorable for me I actually
met Heather before we even got to campus
on a trip to Singapore Malaysia that was
organized in the context of our program
and so we spent two weeks in those two
countries learning about their approach
to artificial intelligence and big data
and it was like such a great opportunity
for me to meet some of my classmates
from different backgrounds to get to
know them in a bit of a smaller
environment and to really feel like I
had a lot of friendly faces on campus
when I already got there and on top of
that I got to learn about a new industry
you learn about two new countries
experience their culture which was
really exceptional this is a fun
question so can I add two more yeah
quickly so when so Karl and I are very
very good friends I actually had the
honour of introducing Karl for like a
big event that he did on campus he gave
a big speech and so that was a really
memorable
I think opportunity for us together um
and then for me um another big piece
because we're arbuckle fellows we had
the opportunity to take the
interpersonal dynamics class last spring
and and that's sort of a small group
type learning focused on yeah
self-awareness sometimes it's called
touchy feely and that course had a huge
impact on me not only in a professional
setting but how I approach my
relationships and friendships and um has
really impacted a lot about how I live
my life yeah those two are also really
really impactful experiences for me
definitely next can you speak more on
the health care focused opportunities
both at the GSB and beyond for example
classes clubs exit opportunities etc I
think I can take that one
I've taken a lot of health care classes
both at the GSB and what we call across
the street so in other Stanford
faculties I've taken one on innovation
healthcare where each class is about a
different segment of the healthcare
industry we had lots of speakers come in
CEOs a pharma company is a biotech
company is of drug discovery medical
device company is to talk to us about
how they perceive the industries what
are the major trends within their
segment and that was super interesting
for me to see healthcare from the sort
of the business perspective rather than
the clinical perspective I'm also taking
a healthcare operations management class
where I've learned how to take large
chunks of data of the hospital patient
transfers and then like see in a
consulting type of project how we could
optimize transfers between the different
departments in terms of the club our
healthcare club is very active they
always organize brown bag lunches with
different speakers from startups and
large companies alike they organize this
week Trek to a bunch of the startups
operating in the mental health space in
Silicon Valley and they're also
organizing a large conference later in
the spring and finally we're asking
about exit opportunities I think there's
people who do all sorts of things within
healthcare whether health care investing
in VC some people will go work at
healthcare startups some people will do
general health care administration some
people like me will work in ask
clinicians with leadership roles within
the healthcare system and so I think the
world is kind of your oyster within the
healthcare industry once you leave leave
here is there anything you wish you had
known or done differently before coming
into the MBA yes I think that the
opportunities that you're presented at
Stanford are numerous there's always
going to be a lot of competing options
for your
time and attention at any given time
there's four brown bag lunches that you
want to go to and they're all great um I
just had it with sending emails with my
co-founder I was like I'm gonna go see
this former founder can you go talk to
the VC people in the other room and so
um it's a matter of making choices about
the opportunities that you take and I
think something that would have helped
me was to do a little bit more
introspection and figure out my focus
and goals before I came here I had this
general idea that I wanted a reason or a
mission to get up in the morning and to
go to work and that was doing good in
the world but I had no idea what that
meant and I think a tangible example of
that for me as I was applying for our
impact fund and we do investment deals
in a variety of areas and financial
technology healthcare education energy
and environment Urban Development kind
of all over the place and they asked us
to choose what we were interested in and
I knew that I was interested in
investing in things that were good for
the world but I had no idea which of
those species I was actually interested
in and that meant that I was kind of all
over the place and I didn't focus and
once I was able to sort of narrow in on
what it was that I truly cared the most
about well I've got a lot easier for me
it was a lot easier to say no to things
that weren't quite relevant I think
there's always this element of oh well
everybody dropped their resume at Google
like I should probably drop my resume at
Google too and maybe that's true but
maybe it's not and so just knowing some
of these things about yourself before
you come here and all of these shiny
objects they're thrown out you know I
think can be a really helpful exercise
yeah I'll go in a slightly different
direction for this one I wish I had
known more about the power of first of
Stanford Network but also of a Stanford
email an example that I've given a few
people recently is that over the past
month I've emailed for hospital CEOs
just to ask them to sit down and chat
with me and all four of them responded
three out of the four responding within
24 hours and and we we set up a little
like small short calls of like half an
hour and they were all like very willing
to tell me about their experiences
how they got to where they got and to
give me advice on how to get where they
are at and so had I known about that
earlier I think I would have taken much
more advantage of that last year even as
soon as I got my Stanford email when I
first got it what has been the greatest
challenge you have faced at Stanford
okay okay I'll take that one um I think
two things first I'm an international
student and so adapting to new culture
and a new country has been more
difficult than I anticipated especially
because I I come from Canada so I
expected the culture to be very similar
but there are some differences in terms
of the politics in terms of the culture
the cultural references and so it was
kind of interesting for me to realize
that I was in a very different
environment sort of midway through my
Fall Quarter and had I braced myself a
bit more for that I think my transition
would have been a bit smoother and the
other thing is time management
like as Heather was mentioning there's
so many opportunities that are thrown at
you here all the time but it's hard
sometimes to decide which one is the
best use of your time
I would definitely echo time management
I think for me the second dimension is
much more personal and that's that my
husband lives in Chicago and so we're in
a long-distance marriage we got married
two months before I moved here to start
my two-year MBA program and and that's
hard we're doing well but of course we
would rather be together um so I think
just figuring out I think a lot of
people struggle with how to balance
their relationships and lives pre GSB
with the fact that this is an
all-consuming experience and that you
really want to be present for and take
advantage of over the two years that
you're here and so finding that balance
for yourself and how to take care of
yourself and your other relationships
outside of the GSB what's the single
most important area Stanford has offered
you to improve your market value so far
my market value yeah that's a very
interesting one I think I have an idea
actually
great I would say it's made me more
aware of my market value anything I
think like as someone who was more an
individual contributor I didn't realize
how valuable the skills that I already
possessed before the GSB were and I
didn't realize that there were so many
different things that I could be doing
within and outside healthcare with what
I've learned both here and before and so
I think Stanford has taught me to think
big and know that if I work hard and if
I am passionate about what I'm doing I
can accomplish a lot of things that I
never even thought were possible in the
past I'm gonna work this in two
directions I think first what I think
outside perception of my market value is
and then like where I actually think my
market value has improved the most from
an internal perspective because I think
those are different things
I'm from the outside perspective
honestly just the signal of a Stanford
MBA credential is what I think has
improved my market value the most like
there are groups that I emailed
beforehand as a consultant not a very
good consulting firm prior to the GSB
when I was kind of thinking about
different career options when I was
debating between that in business school
and I never got an email back and then
suddenly you are a stand for an MBA and
everyone emails you back so just having
the credential is in of itself of market
value and and that feels a little
transactional to say but I think it's
there and and then internally where I
actually think that I have games the
most market value is in the soft skills
absolutely I think that before when I
was in really high pressure consulting
environments it was easy for me to be
impatient or speak sharply in a way that
would could be demotivating to a team
and I've really learned how to adapt
sort of a firm style with being a little
bit more empathetic and when I think
we'll maybe they'll come across in
interviews maybe they'll be valued but
they will certainly be valued when I'm
managing teams or leading teams in the
fact that I feel much more equipped to
develop and grow it
to their utmost potential how
collaborative is the GSB environment do
the second-year students help with
recruiting preparation if the classroom
dynamics friendly yeah classroom
dynamics very friendly
we have a student agreed upon norm here
of grade non-disclosure and which means
that to recruiters you aren't allowed to
share your class rank you're not allowed
to share your GPA and so it's super
collaborative like I think last year
people were building study guides and
sending them out to the entire class
saying hey you know I compiled all the
slides good luck on your finals
so definitely collaborative and helpful
it's not competitive I don't think at
all and then the question do second-year
students help with recruiting
preparation yeah I think so a large
portion of our class is interested in
slightly more entrepreneurial ventures I
think where I see the most help in
career preparation is that if there's
somebody that's in the field that you
want to go into they will if you email
them and they're like hey can we sit
down for 30 minutes for coffee they will
tell you about their summer experience
we do a ton of panels I'm like what did
I do last summer how did I go through
that process what did it look like um
and then there are a few things that are
a little bit more institutionalized and
so um for consulting for example I ran
cases with a lot of people last year to
help prepare them for their case
interviews and you maybe you can speak
more about that from your perspective
yeah I was recruiting for consulting and
obviously we have a lot of classmates
worked in consulting we have consulting
club and so I leaned into both of those
resources pretty heavily to prepare for
my interviews and that was honestly that
made the difference between me getting
the job or not at the end of the day and
so I think it's incredibly collaborative
the other thing I'll say about that is
that we all become kind of known to each
other because the class size is small
enough that you have it at least an idea
of what people are interested in whether
I like a little bit and so whenever I
hear of an opportunity and social impact
or in
for example I'll think of Heather
immediately and if she hears of
something within healthcare like
healthcare systems policy like she'll
think of me
and so opportunities kind of get
redirected a lot like that which is
super helpful for us to achieve her
goals and learn about things that we
wouldn't have heard about otherwise I
think people are super generous with
their networks here I'm and pass along
job opportunities that might be of
interest all the time and if there's
something that you mentioned they'll be
like oh I have a friend that does that
let me introduce you so I think that's
been super helpful yeah definitely how
was your experience with the application
process and what is your piece of advice
to potential applicants great and I
think this will probably have to be our
last question I think so the experience
with the application process
I think Stanford was by far the most
involved application that I completed so
I would say open it up and look through
it entirely well in advance of the
deadline if you if you know the essay
prompts and you think you'll just do
that and fill in your name and address
there's more to it than that
so look in advance um but overall that
application process was great um I think
my advice for you is well first of all
again this is a black box none of us
knows exactly why we were admitted so we
don't say anything on behalf of the
admissions office and and for me I think
it was really important to me that I
show that I was a well-rounded person
who had interests and passions and just
things that I cared about outside of
work and if you have turned your passion
into your work that is great talk about
your work by all means but show all the
facets of your personality yeah I think
the only thing I'd add to that is just
try to be as authentic as you can none
of us know what the admissions office is
looking for so you may as well be
authentic self so that you know that the
person they accepted is the person you
actually are not a person that you've
tried to manufacture for an admissions
committee I think they're very
intentional about creating a community
and you want to be you want to know that
you're the person that they wanted as
part of this community self-reflection
is good
definitely so we're almost out of time
unfortunately but before we go Heather
do you have any final words to share
with the applicants or a piece of advice
mmm this is the greatest two years ever
I'm so just have fun try not to stress
too much um I
the application process seems
never-ending but it's really worth it on
the other side so yeah try to enjoy it
and use it as an opportunity for
self-reflection and then do more of that
over your two years of business school
wherever you go amazing thanks everyone
for joining us and we hope you learned a
lot over the course of this panel
[Music]